I work at scanadu where we have a bunch
of really amazing scientists doing
cutting-edge stuff developing medical
devices for the next generation to
really put data in the hands of people
beyond what what we've seen and I want
to demo for you today just one little
piece on that journey an educational
device called scout and demo on Kevin
just because it would be so fun you open
up the Scout here this is I have to turn
it on and connect the bluetooth so this
is a little thing made of plastic looks
like that very pretty rented yes yes do
be printed prototype so I'm going to
cover this I'm going to hold it here
right that's right so one finger he's
covering a little wonder sensor a little
metal thing than holding here yeah and
to get like this electronic of some sort
right yes a whole bunch of second you're
not connected right now you are so I'm
using my left hand you're using your
left hand because you're completing a
certain i'm making a circuit of some
sort right it goes through your finger
all the way around to your forehead and
i'm going to put it on my temple here
i'm not going to press it into my head
right just put it on my head just put it
on your head and our feed turned off
click on here yeah so there's little
little squiggly lines on the on the
phone is that that is correct i'm not
sure why it's not showing on the screen
but what can we get the screen back up
or can you zoom in on the phone zoom in
on the phone oh here we go
we back up and rescan here too there we
go so scan again the red line is heart
what heartbeat is ECG and the green line
is a PPG or plasma plethysmograph that's
looking at the fluctuations in the in
the blood vessels and the vertical lines
there are noise from the stage somehow
whether I have your heart rate shot up
oh yeah it was 56 before yeah but the
basic idea is that technologies like
this when wunderlich did his thing his
thermometer was over a foot long and and
took 20 minutes to get a reading and now
it's easy to get readings fast on your
vitals and now with with cell phone so
with the analytics like Stephen Wolfram
was talking about you can actually plot
curves this is a 24 hour curve a seven
day average of a 24-hour curve and shows
what a temperature might look like and
one temperature that could be normal
another time it could be completely
abnormal in another so we want to blow
away the idea of a point in time being
accurate for temperature but the same is
true for most things for blood pressure
it's a curve that varies on different
things during the day cholesterol level
know your numbers it's a curve it's not
not one number and it changes throughout
the day and by getting our curves
together it's not just living by the
numbers that's foundational but now it's
living by calculus learning the changes
in the curves and we have the analytics
to do it where we can understand our
personal health ecology